we have a voicemail number?
That number is two one nine two David p.
This voicemail is warning me about something
that may Destin us for failure on twitch.
Is that a word to Destin us?
I hope it is a, the David Pakman show has
launched on twitch.
Twitch is primarily a live streaming platform,
a twitch.tv/david Pakman.
I've been doing a bunch of live streams.
They're taking audience questions, taking
political tests and doing all sorts of different
sort of long form content that we don't typically
do on the broadcast show and one of the great
ways to support us on twitch is if you have
an Amazon prime account, Amazon lets you subscribe
to us with something called twitch prime.
It doesn't cost you anything because every
Amazon prime member gets a free twitch prime
subscription every month.
But it counts as a paid subscription for us.
So that's really great.
But here's a warning about that from a, uh,
someone who is savvy with twitch.
Take a listen to this.
Hey David, this is ty calling.
I just wanted to give you a quick flips up
about twitch prime in, um, in that people
need to subscribe to that every month.
So after every 30 days they'll have to go
back around to twitch and re click that subscription
button, whereas a regular paid subscription
on twitch prime, uh, not, excuse me, not Twitter,
I'm just on twitch.
Yes.
Uh, we'll just automatically renew.
So again, if you subscribe through twitch
prime, you actually have to physically go
through the [inaudible], the process of clicking
that subscribe button again in 30 days and
every 30 days ongoing in order to remain a
subscriber to the channel.
All right, thanks.
So thanks a lot, Rachel.
Yep.
So listen, I mean I think this is of course
by design, the idea of giving people a twitch,
a free twitch prime subscription is that they
do it for a month and then they convert to
a fully paid membership, which I would love
for people to do on twitch.
But the reality is that a lot of people just
want to support us with that twitch prime
subscription.
So this is something we need to figure out.
A obviously on streams that I continue to
do.
I can remind people, hey, check your twitch
prime status.
They expire automatically every 30 days.
Please.
Resubscribe it still costs you nothing, but
you've got to click that resubscribed button.
But I'm open to hearing from people in the
audience about the best way to do this.
People more familiar with twitch and who are
on there, uh, potentially a great source of
revenue for us, but this automatic, uh, expiring
and having to manually renew, I think will
be a challenge that we'll have to sort of
figure out and overcome.
I want to hear from you about that.
In the meantime, follow me on twitch, twitch.tv/david
Pakman.
Hope you'll join a live stream there for totally
different types of content than what we're
doing on our other platforms.
And I also hope to see you on the bonus show
today.
We will be talking about a bunch of different
stuff, including Ohio State University wanting
to trademark the word the, we will talk about
more than 200,000 people signing a petition
to rename Trump towers street after Barack
Obama, which is interesting.
And also more research showing the promise
of ecstasy MDM, a, uh, as a treatment for
PTSD.
We've covered this before on the show and
I wanna dig into it.
On today's bonus show, become a viewer of
[inaudible],
the bonus show by becoming a member@joinpacmandotcomorapatronatpaidfreon.com
slash David [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.